yeah welcome to this video plank I like
see one from the Netherlands yep we got
this is Mark timmermans yeah the master
from the Netherlands with a very high
blitz rating let's see I played him
twice but not sure if this was when when
this some when this happened this must
have been a while it doesn't play that
often yeah he's very high rated them if
it was f 1 i'm against struggling what
did too no he doesn't ok here c 6 g 5 is
okay
check
check yeah that doesn't look very
ambitious black just has a good center
here d 4 is something that I would like
to play maybe I am no okay I couldn't
have played it without cancelling first
deform to allow a possible 95 okay it
doesn't really do anything against it I
thought he should play I'm d3d for
himself so what is his point probably
that he had texted form okay i'm still
trying to go to you three pinning the
night on youtube
93 cookie 1k is a good tactical player
as you can guess I mean that it looks so
seriously speaking this white setup
looks a bit strange but he's some very
very tricky player I watched her I think
he has a he uploaded a couple of videos
to YouTube it's nothing regular but he
did and that it always was kind of a
tactical skirmish he also play some some
funky openings like one before and so on
so what is his point there Knight to f5
or 92f oh I guess yeah
cannot go f5 maybe let's just
centralized this looking at a to a
little bit yep just defended this I
cannot go at five unfortunately i would
like to do that but he can take it you
can take this looks a bit strange but
you can yeah okay maybe just okay of
course I'm trading him it's just okay
for me Jack we can play this for
invasion maybe maybe I get an f5 after
all gaining the space Knight year and
for f3 and g4 so okay a5 is blundering
stuff okay didn't help that was not
helpful
if I go here for 93 k protected that one
so maybe I wonder if f5 is a good idea
yeah okay it's it's a it's a person
I've king of six next so it's I have
good control this his night there is
some is a bit as we dominated yeah to h4
would be good ok is not threatening to
take at the moment I wonder if this is a
good move if I think it's check and I'm
always ready to take with the night I
can go here into III now just invading
Isis his out whole night if who is
always playing for those four tricks
dangerous
Luke g1 might be good no I came check
triumph or h4 g3 if possible 95 of
course also as in the in the position
okay still for work g3 rock g3 and 9 97
96 checkmate that would be cute probably
not possible to have to get on the board
this night is very his light is very
nicely dominated this also root g two
[ __ ] quite we just allows that this
is this is crazy already check check
check just invading now I don't know if
there was the best but it's not it's not
bad to just invade here soul King up to
g3 on there's something better Knight f3
g5 that's also cooked also good Nigerian
h3 kind of thing
just taking the snow getting the pawns
so check time warning
stop the pawns them and now try to I do
I win with with the pawns alone okay 96
46 ok let's go to d3
I'm not running into some stupid trick
them I'm always up for that check check
mmm yeah I spoil this unbelievable
unbelievable to any kind of trick
they're like checkmate on the edge of
the board and probably not yeah okay
game yeah I'm not losing and not winning
this is so bad it's so bad this winning
end game Ian it was ever this is a shame
really because i outplayed him so nicely
Jack never got anywhere how how could i
get my life easier there maybe this
wasn't wasn't the best of ideas just for
keeping things simple i can go to g3
this is not this is not a good idea why
did I allow 90 for them Kim bastard do
this yeah that's probably probably a
jack I mean if he check then going then
going back night he end up picking up
those pawns add must be a win somewhere
yeah this is a position that is some
slightly more comfortable for black but
Tim yeah here it gets it gets quite
tricky an idea three was was interesting
as well check
this is a funny funny I Jack this thing
but I can go here and this is not clear
with Luke here I didn't see that of
course but a hive is also just a good
move it it is designed to kill a snide
offer just a bad piece on F to turn
check out think that was okay I really
played it ok this is check the here this
is a question I think that rookie 3 is
of course a great end game but I i might
be better off if I just improve my
position from here because this night is
so bad i mean i'm also have half the
better rooks okay this is amazing maybe
debatable it keeps a big advantage but
it's maybe not not the easiest way to to
play and I could have taken on c3 a bit
I still like my decision check getting
the two passes must be right yeah i
think it was okay i just i just spoiled
it around him by not being a precise
enough okay well thanks for watching